[Music]
the following program contains the
opinions of its hosts
and guests not those of this network the
opinions expressed are for
non-commercial
informational purposes only listeners
are cautioned
not to rely on program content to treat
or prevent
disease but are advised to consult with
a licensed health care professional
where they live
for diagnosis and treatment of disease
and now the superstar of alternative
health and purveyor of medical truth
dr joel wallach
hello and welcome to dead doctors don't
lie dr joel wallach your host a
veterinarian and physician
and i'm here for kids and baby boomers
and seniors who don't want to die at
75.5
like their parents and grandparents i'm
here for kids and baby boomers and
seniors who don't want to be sick and
miserable for the last 15 to 20 years
their life like their parents and
grandparents
we do have lines open give us a call
toll free one triple eight three seven
nine two five
five two again that's toll free one
triple eight three seven nine
two five five two and today i wanna talk
about
something that everybody's interested in
a long healthy life
okay and uh we have a lot of
which i say um positive things
to look look back at uh you know it's an
amazing thing
but let's talk about current stuff okay
we have
um what we call super centenarian super
centenarians live be 110 years of age
and older
okay and um you know when you look at
the
bible in the old bible days there's
people who live to be
much older than that okay but let's look
at modern times
every country has a list of dozens and
dozens some cases hundreds of super
centenarians over 110 years of age
some recent ones of course the oldest
living human being right now in the
world is a japanese lady by the name of
kane
tanaka she's 118 years of age
well documented and then there's um a
french nun okay her pre-nun
name was lucille randon now his sister
renee
okay she's 117 years old the interesting
thing about her
when she was 116 years of age she got
covered 19
and you know all the people taking care
of her died but she lived right
now she's 117 and just but she lives
in the pyrenees mountains near of course
lords of france for all these
highly mineralized waters now uh kane
tanaka is of course an asian girl
and they asians do very very well when
it comes to longevity
and then we have the blue zones from dan
butener back in i think it was 2005
uh when he published the blue zones and
um the blue zones of course he just took
a blue marker and put a circle
around places on the map where people
lived a long time and they have a common
denominator
there's five blue zones and he said the
reason why they all live so long
in these blue zones is because they're
happy no they're happy because they live
long
and they're healthy and they don't have
discomfort and pain and all that kind of
stuff
it's not their happiness to make them
live longer they're happy because they
live longer
okay and so um
the common thread in these blue zones
with the exception one the seventh day
adventists in loma linda california and
the other four
uh live on either volcanic islands or
peninsulas and things like that where
there's lots of minerals in the soil
because of the volcanic eruptions and so
on and so
you begin to see a pattern here okay you
begin to see a
pattern here of what's going on and the
same thing with people who
um are religious tend to be a little bit
a little bit longer than people who are
not religious
because they're avoiding bad stuff right
and so
there are several things you have to do
number one avoid the bad stuff no fried
foods no processed meats no oils no
glutens and wheat bread around so sugar
um then you need to take the 90
essential nutrients because you don't
you don't live in the blue zones right
you don't you don't live in these places
that have the volcanic eruptions all the
time and so but we do have
access to um uh our
icelandic water and of course they just
have first time in 800 years another
volcanic eruption so be getting some
more minerals are
in our icelandic water but i want you to
get a hold of the book
and the cd uh immortality and of course
the cds called beyond immortality goes
into all these
cultures that live a long time and have
the most super centenarians
because of their diets and where they
live and so on it's not a genetic thing
it's not a racial thing but it's their
diets and their cultures and where they
live
and so i also want you to get a hold
um of the book rare earth been cures
everybody should be taking a hair
analysis once a year
okay and the book rares vancouver's
tells you how to do all that
and it'll tell you if you're absorbing
so if you've been taking in any
toxic metals don't just guess okay
the hair analysis will tell you how to
do all this
and then of course um let's see here
we also i want you to consciously take
the 90 essential nutrients just like
putting
oil in your car as opposed to putting
dirt from texas in your car you're more
likely to have a car that
goes longer same way if you're taking
the 90s essential nutrients you're just
not hoping that you're eating well and
getting everything you need because the
food looks good and tastes good
and so you have to be more conscious
than that okay
and proactive and so um also your immune
system
will protect you when you're going there
and i want you to get a hold of the book
hell's kitchen and the cd hell's kitchen
um it goes into the history of modern
pandemics and plays like the old bible
days
and then of course you also
want to get a hold of the book black
gene lies there are no genetic diseases
in
black folks okay that's all nonsense and
so there's a very popular book in cd
uh black jean lies and so you even if
you're a white guy or an asian guy you
want to read that stuff because the same
truth
for a black guy is true for a white guy
and an asian guy and native americans
because it's a dietary thing a cultural
thing is not a racial thing
okay and um don't forget all in your
head that's one of my newest books i got
two books in the pile coming
um out here pretty soon and it'll be an
earth shaker
okay i'm not going to tell you much
about it now but i'm i'm like i'd say 75
of the way through and these are earth
shakers they're going to add 25 to 50
health for years your life
but these are things you have to be
proactive about all the time you can't
cheat you know
on friday nights you can't cheat one day
out of every month or one meal out of
every month
you have to do this i mean really really
really do it
okay and if you do you will add 25 to 50
healthier your life
if you look at professional athletes
they make maybe a million bucks a game
some of them
and yet their average life span when you
take all sports combined is 62 except
for basketball is 51.
okay emergency room
surgeons
their average lifespan according to cdc
just
about nine months ago was oh their
average lifespan is 57.
we want to go there back after these
messages
you're listening to dead doctors don't
lie on the cbs
radio network if you'd like to talk to
dr wallach call us between noon and 1
pacific
at 831-685-1080
toll-free 888 379
[Music]
many believe that all life began in the
earth's oceans
we do know that the oceans and seas are
still abundant with life
and life-sustaining nutrients many
cultures
have long believed in the life-giving
properties of plants
and sea life harvested from the oceans
youngevities ocean's gold
is a proprietary blend of seaweeds
algaes
mosses kelp sea cucumbers and sea
minerals
as well as coenzyme q10 calcium
and iron all designed to help support
healthy thyroid function
regular heartbeat normal weight mood
stabilization
and hormone levels take advantage of
life-sustaining nutrients
from the earth's oceans with
youngevities ocean's gold
if you'd like to learn more about
nutritional supplementation call your
local youngevity associate and don't
forget to ask about home-based
business opportunities hello judy de
vilvis here
if i could only afford to get one
product out of
everything that product would be the
ultimate
classic it has the vitamins the minerals
the bioflavonoids it even has grape seed
extract
the one product that would give you just
about everything
under the sun you would need for a
perfect nutritional program
would be the ultimate classic by the way
people that are on the go it's very very
hard to take the liquids with them when
they go on their trip
to get their supplements in every day
well you know something you can use the
ultimate daily
tablets and the mineral capsules
when i'm going on a trip if i have
enough room i just take the two bottles
with me
if not just use a little baggie and take
a couple of daily doses with you it's
very simple
it's very easy there's no mess no fuss
no refrigeration
just take your capsules take your
tablets and you're finished for the day
to order these products call your local
youngevity distributor today
[Music]
we're back with dead doctors don't lie
the zvs radar network dr joel wallach
here for young giving
ninety-five percent we do have lines
open give us a call toll free
one triple eight three seven nine two
five five two again that's toll free one
triple eight three seven nine two five
five two and you want to get a hold of
these books and
cds dvds go to www.drjwalk.com
www.drjwalik.com
now india didn't learn much of a lesson
after the 1918 spanish flu they had the
worst number of cases i mean they had
20 million people die in six months they
had 110 million people infected
okay in that same six months and
you know the world kind of got together
and they got vaccinated and they did
this and they did that and
after two three years this spanish flu
went away
well they didn't change their basic
things and so right now
the indians from india are really in
trouble again
they're having about 3 500 3500 new
deaths a day
they are also having 360 000 to 400
000 new infections every day so oh every
three days are going up a million new
cases right now there are
21 million 21 million
um 664
700 uh infections okay just a couple of
weeks ago they were only at 16
million but they're going up every three
days by another million now and they're
really spiking like they did in 1918 a
little over 100 years ago
so uh i urge everybody to pay attention
to these details
uh get rid of all the bad stuff out of
your life no fried foods no processed
meats no oils no glutens or wheat brown
rhinos
no sugar take your 90 essential
nutrients use the big hammer right now
uh healthy brain and heart pack use our
colloidal silver uh orally
uh use our hand sanitizers use our
rebound or sports drink with 100
nutrients in it
and get involved get your families
involved everybody's goal should be
a super centenarian okay doug what
pearls of wisdom do you have for us
today
well i've got a story here headline
chili peppers help reduce the risk of
death from heart attack stroke and other
causes italian researchers looked at the
diets of about 23
000 adults in the southern region of
italy over the course of eight years
finding that those who ate chili peppers
four or more times a week
were more than 50 percent less likely to
die from stroke compared to those who
never ate them or didn't eat them much
and 40 percent
and 23 less likely to die from heart
attack and other causes respectively
a diet emphasizes uh they're talking
about the mediterranean diet here
emphasizes fruits vegetables whole
grains beans nuts seeds and
which actually incorporates the chili
pepper and they say many of the health
benefits of the chili pepper
are attributed to the capsaicin that's
found in the chili peppers that's what
makes them spicy
studies have shown that capsaicin helps
to treat uh
and prevent coronary disease in people
with low levels of high density
lipoprotein or hdl and hdl cholesterol
is beneficial to your heart because it
lowers your risk of a disease from
heart disease and stroke it fights
inflation fights diabetes
boosts metabolism promotes weight loss
and relieves pain so there you go get
some chilies going
[Laughter]
um yeah and of course as part you know
that's a small part
um everything is just like in your car
you test the air in your tires
you check your oil levels you check your
water level in your radiator and
you know you put antifreeze in there
even during the summer time to keep the
engine cool
uh you put heavy grease and oil into the
crank case
uh and so on and so you have to do the
same thing
for your body you have to really pay
attention all the details
and that's why you need to be educating
yourself because the medical doctors are
not educated in this medical doctors are
only educated to maintain
and manage diseases with the exception
of infectious disease things like um
and then they get a bunch of them wrong
um you know
they have antibiotics and of course
antibiotics will kill staphylococcus
streptococcus salmonella and that kind
of stuff
but other than antibiotics all other um
medications and pharmaceuticals treat
the symptoms
okay and they manage the disease okay
and that's how they're able to treat you
like a dairy cow
and they milk
your insurance policy they don't feel
guilty about that well you know i'm not
charging the patient
licenses in alaska hawaii tortured
massachusetts north dakota south dakota
or utah
if you're looking for a quality
multivitamin and mineral product
grab yourself youngevity's beyond tangy
tangerine
a blend of plant-derived minerals
combined with vitamins amino acids and
other beneficial nutrients
this all-natural product contains no
starch wheat
or yeast with no artificial sweeteners
or preservatives and
it's glycemic friendly each scoop of the
nutri crystals contain equal amounts of
all the nutrients
it starts out as a liquid then is freeze
dry to ensure each
scoop has the same nutrients as the last
scoop
so if you want to get your hands on a
quality nutritional supplement designed
to give the body the raw materials it
needs to rebuild
youngevity's beyond tangy tangerine is
available
in one pound canisters and also in 30
count
on the go stick packs contact your local
youngevity associate and get this great
multivitamin and mineral product and
don't forget to ask
about the home-based business
opportunity
we're back with dead doctors don't lie
on the eds radio network dr joel wallick
here for young giving 95 crusade we do
have lines open give us a call toll free
one triple eight three seven nine two
five five two again that's toll free one
triple eight three seven nine two five
five two
and if you wanna build a young giving
business i urge you to get a hold of
these boxes of the thirty little
individual
um envelopes with a rebound sports drink
in it
uh get your business card and either
scotch tape or
staple not you know or the meat of that
thing but just on the edge
to your card and hand those out you know
every place you go
say hey we're you know looking to help
you be healthy and have plenty of energy
with our breathe out 100 nutrients and
it's the only sports drink with 100
nutrients and
75 minerals but also give it a taste and
see how you like it see what it does for
you
and call me and let me know what's going
on here because we're looking for help
and you can make some extra money and
make it earn enough money to pay for
this stuff for free
okay uh doug let's go to callers
all right let's head to uh california
and madrew you're on with dr wallach
well hello my drew how can we help you
hi dr wallach
i have a lady i remember about five or
six years ago we were at the beverly
hills um
library and there was a lady that had
for the lake to the leica
and i have another person you know i was
telling her
basically because that's similar to what
michael jackson had
and i told her it was an immune issue
and other things so i i have a weight
and everything and i
want you to because you could if you
could expound on it so sure
okay sure what's your weight
um 160 pounds well ken how old is she
she's uh 61. okay
now um does she have other issue or is
vitiligo
her main problem that's the main problem
i mean okay do she does she have a wider
grain here
does she have a white gray hair she
mixed hair but she's turning really
white i mean just okay it's like
okay what about okay what about varicose
veins spider veins in her legs her feet
yes yes she's got something okay okay
does she have any
yeah she wears long socks right okay and
then
what about hemorrhoids does she have
hemorrhoids
she says she's got tiny ones well it's
kind of like being tiny pregnant
yeah yeah okay so okay charmaine what
would you do from a drew's friend here
she's a 61 year old woman weighs
160 pounds and
she has a small hemorrhoids she's got
very close veins she's got white hair
she's got vitiligo like michael jackson
lost his skin color is this all a
genetic thing in black people
no no no it's a gluten problem she needs
to get off all wheat barley rye oats no
fried foods no burnt apple fat and no
oils and then because of the weight uh
i would to save money i'd get her on one
healthy brain and hardback and one
healthy
bone and joint pack and then i would
add to that vitamin d3 for absorption
msm which everybody needs which i take
and um ultimate daily classic
and also i would get around some few
coins eve
well there you go and so that's that's
very good prescription there
uh madrew um and these things will turn
around very quickly
because all of them are a nutritional
deficiencies you know michael jackson
died of ruptured aortic injuries when he
was 51
and that is the final straw
okay all these things are caused by
deficiencies of nutrients the same
nutritional deficiencies it causes a
loss of skin color
varicose veins hemorrhoids and
vitiligo also the same thing causes
aneurysms in the brain and art and
pulmonary arteries which is the ultimate
cause of death here
and he died at 51 because his doctors
told me he had a genetic disease
keep keep us informed on this lady
because she'll have a great testimony
back after these messages and that does
open a line if you ever had trouble
getting in we do have an open line
call us on the priority line
831-685-1080 toll-free 888-379-2552
lines open
[Music]
[Applause]
you hi registered pharmacist ben fuchs
here i've been studying healthy bodies
for 35 years and what i've got to tell
you may shock it may change your life
certainly most people have heard about
carbon monoxide but usually only as a
toxic gas
in fact the toxicity associated with
carbon monoxide the stuff that composes
much of what's called air pollution is
what most of us think about when we
think about
the odorless gas and in fact carbon
monoxide is toxic and a leading cause of
accidental poisonings
and according to the american medical
association it kills fifteen hundred
people a year
and sends ten thousand people to the
hospital every year from leaking
chimneys and furnaces and
water heaters and wood stoves and such
it's one of the toxic compounds in
tobacco smoke especially secondhand
smoke
and make no mistake about it if you
breathe someone else's smoke you're
being involuntarily drugged and toxified
there's lots of ways to protect yourself
from carbon monoxide toxicity
but none is more effective than plain
old ascorbic acid or vitamin c
we're hearing a lot of gobbledygook
about ascorbic acid is not really a
vitamin and not really vitamin c and
while that may or may not be literally
true the fact of the matter is
ascorbic acid which is readily available
and inexpensive
is a very potent nutritional
detoxification substance
in addition to neutralizing the toxicity
of carbon monoxide ascorbic acids
chemical reaction with carbon monoxide
serves to
stimulate respiration that is breathing
further improving carbon monoxide
elimination
even if you're not sure if you're
dealing with carbon monoxide poisoning
or any other toxicity
you never know and using a thousand
milligrams a day of ascorbic acid
is just a good all-around detox
insurance policy
pharmacist been here urging you to go to
kscohealth.com to order beyond tangy
tangerine the healthy start pack and
other nutritional supplements that i
personally use and recommend
you can purchase these premium quality
products at wholesale prices online at
kscohealth.com that's kscohealth.com i'm
a pharmacist that believes that staying
healthy and strong is not only about
medicine it's about giving your body the
raw materials it needs to do its work go
to kscohealth.com make sure you check
out the cool videos too
at kscohealth.com that's ksco health
we're back with dead doctors online the
cbs radio network dr joel wallace here
for youngevity 90 flight crusade we do
have lines open give us a call toll free
one triple eight three seven nine two
five five two again that's toll free one
triple eight three seven
nine two five five two and we want to
get some of this
longevity information um you know
between the books immortality and the cd
beyond immortality uh the book black
sheen lies the cd black sheen lies
the book in the cd hell's kitchen um the
book and and the cd rare earth's been
cured they don't talk about the much
the cd much because we have a cd by the
same title rare earth men curious
and then of course uh praise the lord
and pass the ammunition
no no praise the lord praise the lord
and pass to 90. okay that's a great
story about pastor mike freeman who was
in a coma ready to die and you know we
just
rubbed him miss linda and pastor
freeman's wife they rubbed him all over
with their liquid plant minerals
three days time he wakes up and goes
back down to the studio and interviews
me we have a cd and a dvd called praise
the lord
and pastor 90. everybody should listen
to that one too okay
all right oh yeah www.drjwalik.com get
all that stuff
okay uh doug let's go to callers all
right let's head to
chicago illinois and valetina you're on
with dr wallach
hello valentino how can we help you
hello
hi okay my problem started
was the doctors thought that i had a
ringworm
on my stomach next to the navel
and it started growing and growing
and finally i had pathology done and it
turned out to be great and
loma and larry and now i have it all
over my body
okay how old are you 84.
okay um how much you weigh
160. okay do you have any
noise or ringing your ears or tone like
that
no no okay do you have any balance do
you have any balance or dizziness
problems
i have a little bit of balance i i can't
stand on one foot
okay and then what about any skin or you
have skin problems
any bowel problems any bowel problems
things like
um constipation diarrhea
irritable bowel syndrome anything like
that no i had
sigmoid colon resection so consequently
that led to constipation
okay okay why did you have a resection
why did they cut your sigmoid colon out
because there was uh there was a
where you going blockage
they couldn't even get that
in the last two years diagnosed with a
height of hernia and i have two
diverticular pouches there in my colon
and it came from taking a leave i do not
have hypertension i do not have diabetes
i do have a slight gut issue that i've
been treating with your daily digest
and your aloe and it's because
i had a spasm in my neck from a bad
chiropractor adjustment six months ago
so i've been told that i have a
narrowing of c5
and c6 and i have slight degenerate into
my spine
and i do have pain from that but i will
not
ever ever ever take any more
inflammatories ever again because of
what they've done okay and i've been off
case and dairy
and all of that other stuff for overall
sweet how are you teresa
i'm 59. oh okay very smart young lady
for 59.
you're thinking correctly okay
um let's see here do you have any like
ringing your ears or tinnitus
well when i had that chiropractor
adjustment that was um
considered a a gunstead adjustment i
haven't been able to turn my neck fully
right or left without having pain but i
don't
i slightly have a little bit of ting in
the right ear
okay and then do you have um
balance problems where you need to hold
on going up steps and stuff like that
no okay what about skin issues you have
any skin issues any eczema dermatitis
psoriasis or rosacea
no but i do have recently in the last
couple years i've had developed some
spider veins in my lower
calves okay do you have white gray or
silver here
uh well i have my hair highlighted but
my hair is normally auburn so
not really okay i mean if you weren't
highlighting it
would you have some some you know salt
and pepper and you have some some
some grey not much though okay it's like
being not much pregnant
your history ain't okay been highlighted
for so long
i couldn't really tell you you know what
i'm saying yeah i i understand okay we
only have moments here so sherman what
would you do here for
theresa she's five foot 10 59 years old
160 pounds
she's got some gray hair salt and pepper
she's got miracles veins she's got gut
issues she has a hernia uh
some a little bit of tinging in her ears
and stuff a lot of neck stuff what's
going on with her scalp
well i would guess well she's probably
got
she got osteoporosis of skull for sure
and she's probably got a gluten problem
too she needs to get off all wheat
barley rye or oats
no burnt animal fat no fried foods and
no
oils and yeah because she got all this
gut problem and colon pumps absolutely
exactly
exactly so what are you going to so what
are you going to give her okay
well she needs 100 packs 60 pounds wait
i would get her on a healthy brain
and heart back in a healthy bone and
joint pack
and i would add to that vitamin d3 for
absorption
and i would also add msm to rebuild a
lot of the
cartilage and everything and i would get
around the quite see
also and uh absolutely good for them i
mean actually i would get her on some
ultimate jelly classic too because that
would help her circulation to
speedy speed everything up okay on the
daily classic take three of those twice
a day two miles a month and call us
every two weeks
because you're going to have a great
testimony you're going to help a lot of
middle-aged people
those male and female who have these
issues are very common
they have nothing to do with age they
will be aggravated
when people take prednisone or cortisone
to relieve
pain inflammation because prednisone
cortisone actually
accelerate the loss of minerals from the
bones and connective tissue okay
so initially you might get a little bit
of clinical
benefit but over time it's a negative
and so
you're very wise and so just follow what
char said here call us every two weeks
we'll walk you through this
you are going to save a lot of people an
unnecessary
amount of pain okay and so we're very
very
looking forward to hearing from you and
um i thank you
you know we have a lot going on in
georgia
so we're so very happy to hear from you
and
we'll look forward to you know
eventually here they're going to turn me
loose and i'll get to get out there on
the east coast and so look forward to
seeing at some event
all right um we only have seconds here
so i'm going to go ahead and take it
remind everybody
you get a hold of my book some cds and
dvds don't forget
um things like um uh praise the lord and
pastor 90
black chain lies hell's kitchen
rare errors been cures book mcd and
add 25 to 50 health so here's your life
and we'll be back another day god bless
each and every one of you god bless our
troops god bless our navy seals god
bless the american flag god bless our
national anthem
and god bless america
[Music]
wow
with those hi everyone it's time to
bathe in
pureworks foam and protect yourself from
today's viruses and other nasties
who needs that andy anderson here to
remind you that the way to fight this
is with patented pure works this unique
product is gentle on skin but
kills influenza a and b along with hiv
hepatitis b and c and mrsa yeah mercy
don't touch a doorknob visit a hospital
or see the doctor without pureworks on
that's how you commonly become infected
listen up protect yourself by putting
this on your hands and face like
aftershave even around your nose
the killing power of alcohol in your
usual antibacterial ocean only lasts a
few seconds
there's absolutely no alcohol in pure
works which lasts two to three hours
ladies you'll love how soft your hands
feel don't forget to reapply after
washing your hands and men
and women like the light faint fragrance
phyllis and i like the foam but you can
also get spray or a lotion
by the way it's a great deodorant
contact your young jiminy business
associate
am 1340 komy la selva beach watsonville
santa cruz a surface of zbs
you